bonjour derniers préparatifs avant de
vous accueillir sur le plateau d' europe
hebdo nous sommes à bruxelles
ici au parlement européen dans cette
émission nous parlons des organismes
génétiquement modifiés nous irons en
espagne qui est le premier pays européen
pour la culture des ogm mais d'abord le
tour d'europe avec cette question l'euro
va-t-il survivre à la crise coup de
chaud dans la zone euro après la grèce
et le portugal c'est au tour de
l'espagne d'inquiéter les marchés
boursiers quelques jours après avoir vu
sa note dégradée par une agence de
notation madrid doit tenter de rassurer
ses investisseurs et ses rossé louis
zapatero le premier ministre qui s'y
colle si une gros mots restent entravées
si l'on ressort de ce genre pour chuto
qui insiste une énorme dit regretter ou
ne fait qu tu mais parvient à provoquer
c'est si rapidement un seul effet sur
nos marchés financiers alors ce serait
très grave
oui très grave oui non de lamento tout
cela n'a aucun fondement et le fonds
monétaire international a dit très
clairement il loi les dernières brener
sur l'évolution économique de notre pays
d'ailleurs le démontrer économique des
entreprises
une déclaration qui n'a pas eu l'effet
escompté sur les marchés
la crainte d'une contagion a fait
augmenter les taux d'intérêt accordé à
l'espagne en réaction
madrid a promis un plan d'austérité pour
ramener son déficit public de 11,2 à 3%
la grèce entre soulagement et inquiétude
en échange d'un plan de soutien de 110
milliards d'euros elle se prépare à une
cure d'austérité sans précédent
le programme est fortement basée sur une
contraction des dépenses des
accessoirement sur une augmentation des
recettes
il prévoit en outre c'est une initiation
de demander d'importantes réformes
structurelles notamment matière de
retraite en matière de marché de travail
et en ce qui concerne la nécessaire
réforme budgétaire le plan de soutien
sera lancé le 19 mai prochain 30
milliards de prêts à la charge du fmi 80
milliards à la charge des pays de la
zone euro les mêmes pays qui ont exhorté
le secteur bancaire a continué de
soutenir la grèce le retrait des banques
étrangères pourraient aggraver la
violente récession qui attend la
population grecque pour l'avenir paris
et berlin veulent durcir le pacte de
stabilité qui a prouvé selon angela
merkel sa totale inefficacité la
belgique au bord de l'implosion une fois
de plus les discriminations dont sont
victimes les francophones vivant en
territoire flamand ont fait exploser le
gouvernement d'yves leterme
depuis le 22 avril la belgique est à
nouveau sans tête et les tensions sont
toujours vives
des élections législatives anticipées
devraient se dérouler le 13 juin
prochain
trois semaines avant l'arrivée du pays à
la tête de l'europe la belgique est en
passe de devenir le premier pays
européen à interdire le port de la burqa
dans tout son espace public
la france devrait faire de même un
exemple que silvana koch-mehrin voudrait
voir s'étendre à d'autres pays
l'eurodéputée allemande appel à
l'interdiction du port de la burqa
pour l'ensemble de l'union européenne
voilà pour ce tour d'europe réalisé par
marie laëtitia bouriège et n'aura à nadi
retour à bruxelles au parlement européen
avec nous alejandro cercas bonjour vous
êtes député espagnol porte parole du
groupe des socialistes européens et
démocrates
alors la crise de confiance se propage
en europe après la grèce c'est
maintenant l'espagne qui est attaquée
par les marchés
pourquoi l'espagne pourquoi ces rumeurs
bon ils ont profité
une nouvelle qui déchargent des
qualifications des trois qui sont
reconnus à l'universel avait samedi une
échelle l'espagne est au plus haut
niveau parce qu'elle est vraiment c'est
les pays moins endettés et d'aidé de la
zone euro
mais il a suffi que stan hambourg
descendait
un niveau là la colonisation est en
cours pour que les rumeurs et je suis
leur humeur est bien tard et ses
attaques
la la la la la la vision d'un esprit
quand même d'aider beaucoup de ravages
mais bien sûr mais c'est très
intéressant des moments que nous sommes
en train de vivre et parce que on ne
l'arrête de la réalité il ya les pros la
médiation les projections il s'agirait
et pour sortir les profits des gens qui
sont dans des marchés spéculatifs que
l'investiture et fort ils ont investi à
la baisse ils ont fait un pari d'être
vraiment à la fin on va briser la
capacité les retournements de la dette
et couvrir 10 aileron parce que c'est
une bataille de ses comptes en euros
mais qu'est ce qui a poussé les marchés
a attaqué l'espagne quel est le problème
avec l'espagne n'était pas tout à fait
la même situation que que l'adresse il
ya un taux de chômage très important
dans le pays elle est au chômage
s'étaient chronique dans notre pays
c'est vrai que nous avons eu un taux de
chômage beaucoup plus élevé que l'europe
mais même là nous étions les gens les
chats brille on est champion d'europe
inconsciemment les convives ont été
pendant presque cinq années n'était nous
avions aussi à ce moment le chômage
n'explique pas ces attaques spéculatives
on explique destatis spéculatifs parce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont investi très
fort contre l'euro et que l'on investit
très fort contre la dette souveraine de
certains pays de l'europe
guillaume profiter ils ont gagné des
milliers des millions d'euros contre
hiver en investissant contre l'euro en
investissant en pariant qu'il re va
descendre et à paris ainsi que la dette
espagnole d'autres pays aussi que je vis
et seront les suivantes penser qu'il ya
un risque réel de contagion en europe
mais bien sûr ce qu'ils veulent c'est
province est absolument les spéculateurs
espérait être les maîtres et de l'avenir
de notre pays et de riches et l'europe
et bruxelles l'euro ça c'est le pari
mais les héros primaire et moyen de
réagir en tout cas si elle se montre
malheureusement ceux qui mentent non
aujourd'hui la situation grecque et
pourrait montrer mais la situation
d'autres pays européens c'est que
l'europe malheureusement à une monnaie
unique mais il n'a pas les instruments
économiques ou avoir une politique
économique et comment ils nous n'aurons
pas la possibilité d'avoir la peau de
nous endetter comme européen à taux
raisonnables nous occuper sans dette à
des taux qui disent les marchés allons
le marché guettera coordination entre
les conceptions madame angela merkel
propose de
de réformer le pacte de stabilité en
europe et ce qu'on pensait que c'est une
bonne chose en y incluant la possibilité
de sanctions pour les pays qui ne
respectent pas les règles dans la zone
euro mais qu'elle avait sur la question
s'est pas séparé les masseurs parce que
nous savons mieux le partir et stabilité
a été a été très bien suivie par tous
les pays par mambé notamment avaient a
été excédentaire la télé seul pays est
interdite jusqu'à il ya deux années ce
qui n'est pas forcément le cadre les
français paraissait qui nous manquait
ces gouvernants convives au niveau
européen de dire bon est-ce qu'on peut
attaquer dans certains pays de l'europe
mais pourquoi on règle ensemble la
question de l'endettement public et les
bébés c'est ça que ça sert elle à
l'avenir son show et surtout des maîtres
sous le contrôle de la politique et des
biens communs m les agences de notation
tous les nouveaux systèmes et mécanismes
financière internationale qui j'ai qui
sont en train de jouer autres à la
baisse et tous les dérivés tout le temps
dans le systémicien sa condamnation
juste il grossit avec la disgrâce de
déchanter
la disgrâce et aussi l'état
d'impuissance dans lequel semble plonger
l'europe qui a du mal à parler d'une
seule voix qui essuient dans des
turbulences
au niveau de sa monnaie état des lieux
de cette crise de gouvernance avec
florence maurice un euro qui dévisse
face au dollar une union monétaire en
danger des capitales divisées la crise
grecque premier grand test pour la
nouvelle architecture politique
européenne révèle ses faiblesses au
grand jour retour en arrière ce 13
décembre 2009 les dirigeants européens
célèbre en grande pompe la signature du
traité de lisbonne la nouvelle europe
dit on est en marche sans symbole un
nouveau poste de président stable du
conseil confié à herman van rompuy
l'europe désormais va parler d'une seule
voix cinq mois plus tard celle inverse
qui s'est produit
la crise grecque marque le grand retour
des tractations d'état à état en europe
l'allemagne prisonnière de ses échéances
électorales à louer cavalier seul
quant à herman von rompuy et josé manuel
barroso ils sont restés inaudible sur la
scène internationale on s'interroge où
est l'europe titre le new york times
barack obama lui il n'assistera pas au
prochain sommet union européenne états
unis à quelques jours du soixantième
anniversaire de la déclaration schuman
le projet européen paraît bien malmené
le projet européen semble un peu en
souffrance en ce moment alessandro
cercas pourquoi l'europe selon vous
n'étaient pas capables de s'unir de
parler d'une seule voix complète mieux
résister résister aux spéculateurs
quand l'urgence l'imposé c'est le cas
actuellement écoutez je n'y vais bien
précis sait pas ce qu'est donc on
retourne en arrière vers la nationaliste
aurait tourné vers les ive et vieillards
qui ont compromis l'avenir de l'europe
loin de cette europe rêvé par les fonds
dépensés nous sommes entrés tournée
il ya toujours la tentation de retourner
vers l'isolation certains pays de la
vente sur tout le pays prix fort ils
essayent d'imaginer un avenir qui
restaient tous elle ça serait beaucoup
mieux qu'être ensemble cédric ses livres
s'est pas laissée passer par l'europe
qui qui qui qui est qui qui est dans un
moment difficile
c'est l'érotisme qui s'affaiblit dans la
conscience la manquer dans les
dépanneurs à la main d'un compromis pour
l'europe c'est ça qui cavalent contre le
non au contre et au genou il ya
peut-être une urgence à mettre sur pied
le fameux gouvernement économique ne se
montrent pas con c'est luis zapatero le
plaider pour ça qu'est ce que l'europe
attend c'est parce que nous regardons ce
sont les chances des grecs qui ont un
problème et les gens n'imaginent pas que
les panneaux mais c'est pas parce
anglais en grèce en espagne en france en
italie et au royaume uni même en
allemagne parce qu'ils ne revendiquent
ineris et l'euro ils n'ont pas été
heureux avec la cohésion européens qui
sont contenues en auvergne sont
compliquées les marchés qui sont les
marchés les gens qui sont dans tous les
marchés financières et du monde ne sont
pas contents qu'il y avait une autorité
européenne une capacité européens d agir
si vous êtes optimiste pour l'avenir de
la zone euro
je suis partagé il ya des jours que j'ai
dit mais c'est clair que notre leader
vont comprendre qu'il faut aller en
avant ce marché mais autre jour on
reçoive des deux nouvelles des piques
par contre c'est la tentation
nationaliste défaire est plié scheer
l'arrière éthiques
mais ce sont des chemins historiques en
europe on va essayer dans les prochains
semaines dédiées si nous voulons
vraiment sauver l'europe
on le sait que les tombes les retombées
dans les mêmes des marchés spéculatifs
merci on a bien compris votre message à
landreau cercas merci d'avoir été là vie
que cette partie d'actualité ont rejoint
ensuite françois bonnet et ses invités
pour parler des ogm en europe
et oui direction l'espagne qui est le
premier pays européen producteur d' ogm
cela pose des problèmes entre les
agriculteurs qui produisent avec des ogm
et ceux qui ont fait le choix contraire
regardez ce reportage il est signé
florence maurice et violaine vers mango
l'aragon en espagne et la championne
d'europe pour la production de maïs ogm
juancarlos tente ici de maintenir son
exploitation biologique un choix de plus
en plus difficile à défendre
c'est mon voisin là il est en train de
répondre des herbicides
j'ai porté 3000 à plus ou moins mais la
plupart sont en train de mourir
regardez c'est à cause des herbicides
ces arbres c'est son ultime rempart
contre les ogm
depuis l'autorisation des cultures
transgéniques en europe en 98 ses
voisins s'y convertissent les uns après
les autres dans cette région venteuse le
pollen du maïs circule facilement d'un
champ à l'autre
juan carlos a déjà perdu deux récoltes à
cause des contaminations
le maïs a été contaminé par
pollinisation tout ce qu'il reste de ma
dernière récolte il y a deux ans juan
carlos a donc semé de la luzerne à la
place du maïs chaque contamination c'est
une perte de 12 mille euros et la
disparition d'une variété qui le
protégeait depuis 30 ans et parlait de
conséquences économiques ne veut rien
dire
une semence n'a pas de valeur ça n'a pas
de prix comment estimer le prix d'années
de travail sur une variété historique
c'est une perte pour tout le monde une
perte à l'échelle de l'humanité s'est
perdu et c'est tout
le principe de l'europe en matière d'eau
gm c'est pourtant celui du libre choix
l'union des sites des semences autorisé
et chaque état choisit ensuite de les
cultiver non sept pays ont déjà interdit
le maïs ogm alors pour les semenciers
l'espagne c'est un peu devenu l'eldorado
toute l'année ses représentants sillonne
la région de ferme en ferme comme
aujourd'hui daniel me agronome me wehr
officiellement il est là à titre gratuit
pour donner des conseils
alors ici voilà une de nos nouvelles
espèces demain son génie qu'elle sera
disponible à partir du mois de mars
démarre la technique des semenciers
s'imposer comme des interlocuteurs
privilégiés dans cette région semi aride
en proie aux attaques d'insectes 60 %
des agriculteurs se sont déjà laissés
combat transgéniques pour nous c'est la
tranquillité
on n'a plus à se préoccuper en
permanence de l'état de nos cultures
l'entretien est plus facile
les plantes sont plus vigoureuse c'est
la tranquillité en 2003 après les
premiers scandale de contamination
l'europe à rédiger des recommandations
pour la culture des ogm des
recommandations dites de coexistence
elles n'ont pas force de loi en espagne
mais pioneer est fier de nous montrer
qu'ils les respectent à la lettre
cet écrit lac avant d'ouvrir le sac il
faut lire attentivement le prospectus
recommande de laisser 20 mètres de
séparation entre change est méchant en
oenologie
et aussi de conserver du maïs
conventionnelles sur 20% de la surface
des normes jugée insuffisante par les
écologistes et qui ne font l'objet
d'aucun contrôle par les autorités de
toute façon dans la pratique
la contamination se fait aussi dans les
coopératives par manque de moyens et de
structures elles ont fini par traité
dans le même si yo le maïs transgénique
et traditionnelle
par facilité la totalité de la
production se retrouve de fait
étiquetés ogm rocé angel est l'un des
rares en aragon à maintenir une filière
traditionnelle
un choix coûteux car il exige des
contrôles permanents entreprises qui
achètent le maïs 3000 tonnes par an
analyser les échantillons comme celui ci
à toutes les étapes de la production
dans ce stock un seul grain de maïs
transgénique est décelée rien ne sort de
là
la plupart de ces entreprises qui
achètent du maïs traditionnel ont déjà
choisi de se tourner vers l'importation
pour rosser angel chaque année c'est
donc la crainte qu'un seul grain de maïs
transgénique lui fasse perdre son unique
fils sous couvert de leur donner le
choix
l'europe laisse les agriculteurs seule
face aux conséquences des ogm ce matin
juancarlos pas rencontré le président du
comité aragonais d'agriculture
écologique avec l'espoir de se faire
indemniser pour ces contenus
si ce maïs est contaminée à qui la faute
j'ai pas envie de faire un procès à mon
voisin alors je suis coincé je peux plus
rien faire pour le moment il n'existe
aucun recours
mais pour ces agriculteurs la
responsabilité est politique
antonio ruiz s'est déjà rendu deux fois
à bruxelles pour plaider cette cause
il a le sentiment de prêcher dans le
désert
il se bouche les yeux à la commission
européenne et ils se voilent la face que
font-ils
il autorise de nouvelles variétés de gm
à qui la faute
alors voilà on traverse toute une partie
de l'europe on va de l'espagne
ici à bruxelles pour parler donc des ogm
avec deux invités
sandrine bélier bonjour donc vous êtes
députée européenne française du groupe
des verts et face à vous philippe
gracien bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
le directeur du groupement
interprofessionnel des semences
donc en fait vous êtes le le
représentant en quelque sorte des
semenciers français
je voudrais vous demander à tous les
deux d'abord de ce qu'on fasse un petit
point rapide sur l'état des
autorisations ou des interdictions en ce
qui concerne les ogm en europe parce que
c'est important suite pour peut-être
alimenter notre débat sandrine bélier ou
est-ce qu'on en vit actuellement en
europe vous et je pensais que vous
poseriez la question
on a
donc on a une réglementation européenne
aujourd'hui qu'on juge
et sans surprise assez satisfaisante
il ya un certain nombre d'espèces de
maïs génétiquement modifié qui sont
autorisés
à la commercialisation et à la culture
puisque ces deux types d'autorisation
différentes il faut faire bien les
distinguer le dernier dossier en date on
en a beaucoup entendu parler c'est moi
ce que j'appelle le dossier de la patate
chaude c'est la patate and flora qui
n'est pas a priori destiné à
l'alimentation
mais qui tout de même pose les mêmes
questions les mêmes interrogations les
mêmes problèmes liés à la culture des
ogm des organismes génétiquement
modifiés en plein champ et ensuite voilà
on a et il y avait on aura j'espère
l'occasion de leur parler avant cette
cette autorisation qui est donnée à
l'échelle de l'union de l'union
européenne on a des procédures
d'évaluation qui sont réalisés par une
agence européenne qui est l'efsa et dont
les procédures d'évaluation sont
aujourd'hui à la fois critique et
écrit-il
peut-être alors que dans leur parler
philippe gracien comment vous
qualifieriez comment se situe l'europe
en matière d' ogm par rapport aux autres
continents à par rapport aux autres
continents je pense que madame payée par
les deux réglementations effectivement
l'europe à une réglementation qui est
très stricte qui est compliqué qui donne
un certain nombre de garanties aux
utilisateurs aux consommateurs et aux
citoyens autant sur le plan qualité
sanitaire mais entendu que problème
vis-à-vis de l'environnement compléter
ce qu'a dit même minute je voudrais
souligner que les autorisation à la
commercialisation il ya plusieurs
espèces qui sont autorisés et en
particulier le soja et qui a beaucoup de
soja génétiquement modifiés qui est
importé en europe parce que c'est un des
aliments important pour nos élevages
européens
c'est une source de protéines puisque
nous sommes très déficitaire en europe
en matière de protéines végétales à
quand on est en plein dans le dans le
débat sur sur les ogm
en fait on entend souvent mais il faut
absolument autoriser plus de gm en
europe parce que l'europe est très en
retard est ce que c'est vrai à bas par
rapport à d'autres continents et à
particules le continent américain et les
états unis
c'est vrai que aux états unis il ya
beaucoup plus de plantes génétiquement
modifiées qui ont été autorisés avec
différents types d'autorisation avec des
résistances à des insectes des
résistances à des virus des tolérances
des herbicides
ça concerne le coton le maïs le soja le
colza sont les principales espèces
aujourd'hui qui ont eu des modifications
génétiques en importent s'est produit en
face et ses plantes en france
oui attendons qu'il y ait des
autorisations en europe pour le soja
comme je vous le disais pour le colza et
pour le mail sandrine bélier le
reportage que vous avez vu l'as donc en
espagne avec ce problème autour de la de
la contamination
j'imagine qu'évidemment ce sont des
problèmes que vous connaissez bien
est-ce que ce que vous voyez là je
tairai correspond à ce que vous savez de
la réalité sur le terrain
oui et puis j'aimerais au moins sûr sur
deux points par rapport à la situation
américaine c'est vrai que l'union
européenne est particulièrement
attentive et préoccupé à préserver la
sécurité sanitaire alimentaire et
protectrice de l'environnement plus que
ne l'est plus que ne le sont les états
unis et pourquoi je vais donner
simplement une question d'actualité hier
en commission environnement nous allons
acter le fait de refuser l'importation
de viande clonée
voilà alors peut-être qu'il ya un chemin
avance aux états unis mais en termes de
procédures d'évaluation sur l'innocuité
et notamment d'un point de vue sanitaire
d'un certain nombre dans l'aîné
génétiquement modifiés nous ne sommes
pas aujourd'hui en capacité d'assurer à
la population aux citoyens européens
kylie a absolument aucun danger à long
terme à moyen et long terme par
l'ingestion à l'ingestion d'aliments
génétiquement modifiés d'accord avec ça
le problème du long terme est un
problème difficile et je crois que les
thèses qu'ils ont fait aujourd'hui et
mes textes de toxicité ce qu'ils disent
que effectivement la plante
génétiquement modifiée n'est pas toxique
heureusement autrement ne seraient pas
autorisées bien entendu mais avec des
protocoles et c'est une des choses qu'on
remet en question c'est à dire qu'on a
pour les produits pharmaceutiques
on a des procédures d'évaluation et des
protocoles qui sont particulièrement
précis et qui nous garantisse
véritablement avant la mise sur le
marché d'un produit pharmaceutique une
véritable sa présente aucun danger pour
la santé humaine
dans le domaine des organismes
génétiquement modifiés aujourd'hui les
procédures et protocoles d'évaluation
qui sont réalisées à l'échelle de
l'union européenne sont beaucoup plus je
le disais contesta parce que beaucoup
plus léger et ne s'appuie pas alors
qu'on pourrait le faire sur ces
procédures vous l'avez dit on établit la
toxicité mais on ne va pas jusqu'à
établir et garantir l'innocuité d'un
produit génétiquement modifiées pour
pour la santé humaine
alors on va on va aller on va repartir
quelques secondes en espagne parce que
l'une des personnes l'un des
agriculteurs que vous avez vues dans le
reportage à une question en fait
d'ailleurs trois questions à vous poser
regardez pourquoi est ce que les
agriculteurs qui ne souhaitent pas
cultiver des ogm ne sont pas protégés
par une loi pourquoi est ce que tous les
produits fabriqués à partir de gm ne
sont pas correctement étiquetés pourquoi
est ce que les industriels ont plus de
pouvoir que les consommateurs alors
voici donc cette question qui veut
répondre peut-être vibrations voulait
alors l'étiquetage irien des règles
communautaires en matière d'étiquetage
puisque tout produit qui contient des
ogm ou qui fabriqué à partir d'éléments
content deuxième de tetra dictée et même
si un produit n'est pas fabriqué à
partir de gm mais qui contient deux
factions accidentelle +20 9% de gm il
doit être étiquetés comme contenant des
ogm
donc là aujourd'hui c'est que la
proportion par exemple des produits qui
ont des ogm et ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
dans l'alimentation humaine il ya très
peu de produits aujourd'hui qui
contiennent des ogm par contre dans
l'alimentation animale comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure mais la plupart
des protéines végétales que nos animaux
consomment contiennent des ogm puisque
ce sont des choses qui sont importées du
continent américain sont essentiellement
on sait peu en fait il ya énormément de
qu'on consomme énormément de deux
produits ogm parce qu'il ya des
importations elles directement ou
indirectement sur les sur l'étiquetage
sandrine bélier les la question qui est
posée là et c'est là notre principale
préoccupation est au delà de
l'application du principe de précaution
c'est la transparence cette question de
traçabilité et la question du choix
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on a une
réglementation qui permet de choisir ce
que l'on a envie de produire et qui
permet de choisir ce que l'on a envie de
consommer moi j'ai tendance à penser que
c'est insuffisant
on a en effet un étiquetage à une
traçabilité encore une actualité d'hier
on a fait on a fait adopter en
commission environnement l'étiquetage de
la viande qui est alimenté par des
produits ogm donc aujourd'hui on voit il
ya un certain nombre d'insuffisances
encore et puis à cette question de
coexistence et du choix d'un agriculteur
de produire du conventionnel de produire
du bio ou de loger m aujourd'hui moi
j'ai le sentiment que le système est en
effet organisée de telle manière qu'il
ya une prégnance du de l'agroalimentaire
sur le monde sur le monde rural et
agricole qui ne laisse pas l'entièreté
du choix on va vous laisser le mot de la
fin
si vous êtes d'accord philippe gracien
parce qu'on voudrait vous montrer
maintenant un tout petit clip vidéo
savait que le 9 mai c'est là c'est la
fête de l'europe cette année en fait en
plus le 60e anniversaire de la
déclaration de robert schuman et la
représentation française de la
commission européenne à paris a décidé
de mettre sur internet un petit clip
vidéo vous allez voir je sais pas si ça
va forcément faire venir du monde pour
la fête de l'europe mais en tout cas ça
fait du ramdam comme on dit maintenant
sur internet regarder
j'ai trouvé le spot pour la crise de
l'europe
ok balance le pitch imagine le 9 mai il
de christmas island
des milliers de crabes se ruent vers une
destination inconnue pourquoi comment le
monde entier s'interroge rennais nation
ils veulent faire la fête avec leurs
cousins européens
jacky forto le coup mais j'ai dit des
mortels
elle est morte au cours du mobile est
incroyable il manque un paroles un peu
plus très peur pour les jeunes et dans
les mines c'est dépassé s'est passé
l'europe et or ont bien utilisé en
orbite bon vieux fichiers bien fait dire
à toi tu es pour l'anniversaire de l'ecr
son chemin face et festif non je pensais
plutôt illustré la nuit entre les
peuples a battu les bleus coûteux bon
alors on revient sur le côté disco
adaptation d'un classique avec le
pinceau candidats
mais c'est quoi la chute qui assure bien
tout le monde en pince pour la fête de
l'europe et mentalement
j'sais pas quoi dire je compte en tout
apprécié mon travail voilà c'est la fin
d'europe hebdo alors sachez que pour la
fête de l'europe il n'y aura pas
uniquement que des crabes mais également
des journées portes ouvertes ici à
bruxelles ce sera samedi 8 mai et à
strasbourg le dimanche 9 mai et on se
retrouve ici même au parlement européen
à bruxelles la semaine prochaine
excellente suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires